hä es wird teuer das merken wir alle
aber viele fragen sich was kommt da nur
auf uns zu das fragen sich ganz viele
Menschen beim Blick in den Geldbeutel
und einige die gehen auf die Straße um
gegen hohe Energiepreise und
Kostenexplosionen zu demonstrieren in
Magdeburg beispielsweise Polizei
1500 Menschen dort auf der Straße und
auch in Brandenburg an der Havel waren
es rund 200 es ist ein wilder Mix aus
Teilnehmern doch sie eint eine Sorge wie
bezahle ich meine Rechnungen denn die
Gaspreise in Deutschland die schießen
durch die Decke und kaum jemand kann das
stimmen
die Gaspreise explodieren sich das
Heizen leisten zu können für viele ein
Problem Preiserhöhungen von über 1.000
Prozent sie sind keine Seltenheit
horende Preise für viele Bürger einfach
nicht mehr zu stemmen und was sagt
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
dazu als es zu Kriegsbeginn um steigende
Strom und Gaspreise geht meinte er nur
am Ende ist es nur Geld es ist ja nur
Geld für viele Menschen einfach nicht
mehr zu bezahlen kein Wunder bei
ständigen Preiserhöhungen wir haben im
April dieses Jahres die erste Erhöhung
bekommen
von monatlich 98 Euro auf 481 Euro
monatlich
und jetzt haben wir im September eine
neue Festsetzung auf 1.047 Euro bekommen
diese können wir mit zwei
vollverdienernanten nicht mehr bezahlen
am Ende ist es nur Geld viele Bürger
wissen nicht mehr weiter haben Angst vor
weiteren Erhöhungen wie auch Kai Luhdorf
aus Schleswig-Holstein seit 1 April
haben wir schon den tollen gastpreis
knapp 28 Cent pro Kilowattstunde ab 1
Oktober erwarten wir noch eine dicke
Erhöhung da die gastrasia weit am
Steigen sind das macht bei mir im Jahr
ungefähr drei bis 4000 Euro mehr
Belastung als vor der Krise wie ich das
bezahlen soll mit den steigenden
Lebensmittelpreisen ich habe keine
Ahnung am Ende ist es nur Geld es sind
die stetigen Preiserhöhungen die die
Menschen vor unlösbare Fragen stellt wir
haben von unserem Gasanbieter mit Gas
eine Preiserhöhung bekommen wo wir
bisher 104 Euro pro Monat bezahlt haben
sollen wir für November
oder auch später das können sie mir
nicht sagen im Monat
1220 Euro bezahlen am Ende ist es nur
Geld für viele Menschen geht es eben um
mehr als nur Geld
es geht nicht mehr das sagt auch Rentner
Dietmar aus Zwickau er hat ein Leben
lang gearbeitet geschuftet und jetzt
bleibt nichts am Ende eines
pflichtbewussten eines fleißigen Lebens
bleibt für ihn nur die Armut
der gaspreisschock in Deutschland er
wird für immer mehr Menschen zu einer
unbezahlbaren Hürde so auch für Dietmar
m aus Zwickau durch den hohen
gasabschlag kann er sich das Leben nicht
mehr leisten diesen Abschluss wurde von
wurde mir jetzt da entfällt aber
November 22 genau ab dem 23
November 22 verlangt die Firma MITGAS
monatlich von mir einen Betrag in Höhe
von
2268 Euro und ich bin nicht in der Lage
diese Summe monatlich zu zahlen das sind
bei 11 Abschlägen knapp 25.000 Euro das
entspricht entstehen Mittelklassewagen
ein Albtraum in Briefform statt bislang
monatlich 165 Euro muss der Rentner ab
November unglaubliche
2268 Euro pro Monat zahlen eine Erhöhung
von über 1.3
70 Prozent ein Schock
wusste ich nicht und nimmst du eine
Flasche Bier oder nehme ich einen
Blutdrucksenker bzw in beta Blogger und
der Herzfrequenz zu senken muss mich
erstmal auf der Treppe setzen und meine
Frau hat gesagt das kann nur
Rechenfehler sein das ist kein
Rechenfehler die Hörner Preisliste
mitgeteilt wo sie auf die kühle
wattstunde von knapp 60 Cent kommen
so das sind noch der veränderte dazu das
lässt sich Dietmar m nicht bieten und
ruft bei seiner Gasfirma an doch das ist
leichter gesagt als getan nachdem ich
den Brief gelesen habe wo ich geschockt
und habe versucht mich mit MITGAS in
Verbindung zu setzen aber auch entweder
ich rief immer außerhalb der sogenannten
Servicezeit ab und als ich während das
durch das seit mehrmals versucht habe
diese Firma zu erreichen war aufgrund
der Futter Vielzahl der Anrufer eine
Verbindung nicht möglich dazu kommt die
Firma mit Gas die die
horror-preiserhöhung veranlasst hat
erklärt sich in ihrem Infoschreiben an
Dietmar m mit diesen Worten wir
versichern dass wir alle Möglichkeiten
ausschöpfen werden um das Preisniveau
für unsere Kunden erträglicher zu
gestalten die Preiserhöhungen für
Dietmar m ganz und gar nicht erträglich
das ist unzumor das ist nicht zumutbar
dass eine Familie wird mit zwei Mann in
gasabschluss
nur von knapp zwei einhalb tausend Euro
im Monat ihm bleibt jetzt nichts anderes
übrig als den Stecker zu ziehen und den
Anbieter zu wechseln damit er sich das
Heizen und das Leben im Winter überhaupt
leisten kann
ja ganz genau es geht für viele Menschen
um die Existenz um die große Frage wie
sollen wir das noch schaffen wir helfen
Ihnen hier im Studio bei uns Frank Ochse
unser sparfox der viele Tipps parat hat
für die Verbraucher was man jetzt tun
kann um Gas zu sparen Frank also ganz
wichtig verschaffen sie sich erstmal
einen Überblick viele sagen ja so
gasrechnen gucke ich mir nie an das ist
jetzt aber ein riesen Fehler tatsächlich
schauen ist irgendwas im Kundenkonto
gelandet per E-Mail oder natürlich auch
Briefe öffnen die da vielleicht noch
unten geöffnet liegen und wirklich
schauen ja wie hoch ist im Moment mein
Preis oder versteckt sich da vielleicht
tatsächlich auch eine Preiserhöhung denn
dann muss ich reagieren und wirklich
schauen ob ich nicht vielleicht doch
noch einen günstigeren Anbieter bekomme
also erstmal wichtig Überblick
verschaffen das ist ja eine Krise eine
Energiekrise wie wir sie nie erlebt
haben Frank womit rechnest du für diesen
Herbst für diesen Winter wenn so viele
Leute wirklich völlig überfordert sein
werden mit ihren Gasrechnungen werden
die massenweise kleinere Wohnungen
suchen müssen ihre Autos verkaufen
beispielsweise womit rechnest du also
tatsächlich sind die Hilferufe der
Bildleser mittlerweile wirklich
dramatisch wir lesen immer wieder in
E-Mails wir können uns das nicht mehr
leisten wir haben es ja auch gerade
gesehen wir sind im Moment bei
Neuverträgen bei 40 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde Gas das ist schon eine
massive Erhöhung im Vergleich von vor
einem Jahr und es wird so sein wir
werden das nicht mehr leisten können da
ist natürlich die Privatinsolvenz
sicherlich steht im Raum da muss man
natürlich mit dem Vermieter verhandeln
wir haben auch gehört es gibt auch
Rettungspakete möglicherweise gibt es
aber noch keine Details also jetzt noch
nicht in Panik verfallen dann müssen wir
uns vielleicht auch ein Stück weit auf
die Politik verlassen und wirklich
erstmal jetzt kühlen Kopf bewahren und
am Ende ist es klingt wie eine Binse am
Ende natürlich auch Energie sparen das
sind echt harte Zeiten ich finde es wird
ein bisschen Angst und Bange und bei dir
da gehen ja auch ganz viele Briefe und
E-Mails von unseren Leserinnen und Leser
und Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern ein
die wirklich nicht mehr wissen wie es
weitergeht jetzt vor der Entscheidung
zum Beispiel stehen soll ich jetzt
schnell wechseln solches irgendwie
schauen zum Grundversorger also was soll
ich jetzt machen hast du da Tipps
absolut das Zauberwort ist Preisgarantie
es ist tatsächlich so das gab es früher
überhaupt nicht oder nur wir sehr selten
als Werbegag jetzt werden wirklich neue
Verträge angeboten mit Preisgarantie und
wenn halt das noch einigermaßen
akzeptabel ist auf jeden Fall mit
Preisgarantie es ist zwar im Moment so
dass in Preisvergleichen zum Teil
Grundversorger günstiger sind als der
Rest aber die werden auch massiv erhöhen
das heißt also ganz wichtig vielleicht
eine 24 monatige Preisgarantie das ist
finde ich ist das ist möglich und das
ist auch wirklich drin aber trotzdem es
bleibt eine mega Belastung und man muss
ehrlicherweise auch sagen dass ich
vielleicht auch einige Versorger da ist
auch die Taschen voll machen da wird
jetzt einfach mal so er also wir haben
ja wirklich da auch ihre Geschichten
auch von Zuschauern gehört das muss man
natürlich auch erstmal überprüfen
natürlich muss ein Versorger das auch
begründen warum jetzt vielleicht um 800
Prozent oder noch mehr die Preise erhöht
werden also auch da lauernd fallen
tatsächlich da wird auch getrickst das
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen und
wirklich schauen Sie sich genau an was
ihnen der Versorger schreibt
[Musik]